as long as I can remember I was a Ninja
Turtles fan
we're bringing to life these characters
were a new generation and the cast is
really funny
it's nice
Brady noon is Raphael I dream about
fighting every night we got Mike Abby is
Donatello you're fine chill Nicholas
Cantu is Leonardo we're really sorry
Spooner some of the guys wanted to get
pizza and I tried to talk him out of it
jeremon Brown Jr is Michelangelo why do
we pick a fruit shaped exactly like my
head you would record the kids at once
the personalities of the characters came
from the chemistry they had with each
other
don't use that word that way I mean it's
2023 dad
Jackie Chan the Splinter he's incredible
anytime you need more call me and Iowa
debris plays April O'Neil this is insane
Turtle Mutant karate I'm excited to lean
into the mutant element of it we had the
designs and then wrote the personalities
of the characters to who's cast six in
the morning police at my dog ice cube is
Superfly saw some little tortoises huh
me and John Cena are Bebop and
Rocksteady what you looking at bro what
you looking at Mondo Gekko is played by
Paul Rudd people's they got to give post
Malone is
fully Rose Byrne plays Leatherhead
Giancarlo Esposito plays Baxter Stockman
Natasha dimitrio plays Wing nuts animal
Burris like Genghis frog Maya Rudolph
Cynthia utram Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle is a comedic action movie with
heart do you think there are people who
will accept us
[Applause]
no no absolutely not
um genuinely no
[Applause]